for five kids run back in their trailer
and then the tornado hit it and they
were gone
[Music]
I've never been through this and I don't
wish it on anybody this is Houston Texas
America's fourth largest city much of it
is now under floodwater streets and
neighborhoods swamped after one of the
heaviest downpours in US history
more than 76 centimeters of rain has
fallen since Friday when hurricane
Harvey made landfall
and it hasn't stopped
the deluge is incessant the floodwaters
continue to rise
destroying lives and livelihoods
emergency services are at breaking point
unable to cope around you know it's all
lost on the bottom floors and you're
trying to save anything you can so it's
a real heartache and it's something that
so it's up to communities to help each
other it's just heartbreaking I look at
these hope and a lot of elderly people
live in these houses so in fact one
couple is back there and I I don't know
if y'all got him out or not but he there
if they did not want to leave they were
up in the upper bedroom and not did not
want to leave so I just hope we can once
this all drains off we can rebuild but I
know it's gonna take neighbor rescuing
neighbor well I feel that you know you
should help your neighbor I feel that
it's the right thing to do I feel that
these people will do the same thing for
me if I grew up around here
the disaster is unfolding on an epic
scale
the storm is generating an amount of
rain that would normally be seen only
once in more than a thousand years no
mass evacuation of the city was ordered
because it was deemed to be too
dangerous to have millions of fleeing
cars the neighbors came over from across
the street
you can help me get my my dog Lexi in
myself out and my four cats that it was
only able to take one path with me and
Lexi and the other three year in the are
you glad to be leaving even though this
is your home yes I'm glad to be going to
my parents home where I grew up but I'm
devastated and everybody lost so much
and it still keeps continuing to rain
Houston wasn't in the direct path of the
hurricane so residents were advised to
stay in prepare but how do you prepare
for this
this truck had to be towed to safety
there's water in your car what was it
like him it came so fast I know what
else to expect I'm just happy I'm here
right now so in the back the drivers
mother a patient who needs hospital care
I have three people water in my house
three people in my bed in my in my
hospital bed it doubts because I'm
bedridden there's hot there's water in
all the beds in the house we've lost
every strip of furniture every couch
everything others wade through the water
with all the possessions they can carry
or push what have you gotten all these
bags whatever you just have to do
clothes my daughter's clothes my wife's
clothes bar a couple cans of food even
for a city that is used to hurricanes
and storms this is unprecedented rescue
services are at breaking point barely
able to cope
there's plenty of people I mean there's
countless amounts of people I mean we've
pile it on like 30 or 40 by ourselves
only and you tell mother you got like 10
12 oh and you got the huge dump trucks
working at the same time non-stop and
you just try to rest you lady with her
dogs but what happened we got to her
home I think she had a little small pit
in the cattle that one didn't make it a
mini ground and the two were up on
furniture emergency centers are taking
more than 1,000 calls per hour but
dealing with the ongoing crisis means
there's a little time to go in search
for more victims
entire communities arrive at evacuation
centers even these are stretched to
breaking point and they're barely able
to cope with the influx I didn't even
imagine that it was gonna be this
catastrophic like this this is for my
two-year-old he told me was scared
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the first time we even seen how
much how much water it has been so it's
crazy
would you like to be
rescued like this
Oh bless that's it a blessing it was
just a blessing to be rescued
unbelievable is just unbelievable
kemberly did we never experienced
anything like this I'm holding up on two
helpless people you know I'm tired but
it's worth it
I mean you're holding an infant this has
got to be a lot of pressure on you yeah
especially baby like this should be in a
rain and cold houston is known as the
city of the bayou
it's criss-crossed by 1,700 miles of
channels and creeks all unable to cope
with the relentless rain causing the
floodwater to keep rising
on Friday the warnings were in place
officials knew about Harvey's potential
for devastation it was predicted to be a
monster storm you may think that the
initial surge is something that you will
be able to deal with what you don't know
and what nobody else knows right now
will be the magnitude of flooding that
will be occurring over the coming days
in the aftermath of the initial surge if
you wait until you realize how serious
this condition is you likely will find
that it's too late for you to be able to
evacuate Texan towns directly in
Harvey's path were ordered to evacuate
okay
and those who chance to remain stocked
up it's a well rehearsed drill but
always a gamble flee or stay and tough
it out for some it's a decision they
nearly came to regret what what happened
how was it last night very scary very
scary I we debated on leaving and then
we thought well we'll go ahead and stay
and then they said it was gonna be a cat
4 but it was a the winds were whistling
and and you could just it sounded like a
tornado if you open the door it was just
a roaring just horrendous roar
we've got lots of trees down back there
more tree from the side part of the
fence has gone over there but if you
look around everybody that's got damaged
everybody and we thought we had it bad
but there's a lot of them got a lot
worse many Texans are now in temporary
accommodation in makeshift shelters
they've watched helplessly as their
homes and lives were wrecked by one of
the fiercest storms to hit the region
Green came flying through somebody
else's yard not the army up up in the
air and then I got the dogs in the house
and by the end tornado had lifted up the
ponies and took in them and I seen the
other family that was with like four or
five kids run back in their trailer and
then the tornado hit it and they were
gone and like two more came across the
other side coming the other way and they
cut a path corn this way and everybody
that was in that area if they were in
the homes there's no way they could have
survived because the homes were leveled
to foundation Margaret all right
Mallory the whole house was gone by the
morning and it lasted for like all night
like I don't understand and our houses
were gone everybody's houses were gone I
got friends out there that I don't even
know they're all right here the man I
guess everybody made their decision and
it was the stay which was the worst
decision they possibly could have made
like we're all lucky to be alive I can
guarantee you that according to some
forecasts when it does stop Harvey will
have dumped more than four and a half
million liters of water for every man
woman and child in southeastern Texas
but for now there is no end in sight to
the misery another 61 centimeters of
rainfall is expected and that means the
flood waters will not recede any time
soon and it's only when they do that the
real cost of this disaster will be known
[Music]